quick little funny story up there's this
back story where reports were that when
president-elect Donald Trump went to the
white house right after winning election
on november eighth electorally and met
with President Obama that number one he
looked shell-shocked in the pictures
that were released after the meeting if
you look at this picture over my
shoulder indeed Donald Trump does look
like he just uh either something to
smack them in the face and he realized
wow what on earth am I in for and a
number of people who were are aware of
what took place there have said sort of
anonymously or or both asking on the
condition of anonymity the Donald Trump
had no idea the extent to which the
president has to actually do stuff we
now have a prominent Republican named
newt gingrich who has revealed that yes
indeed Donald Trump admitted the
presidency is quote a bigger job than I
thought Newt Gingrich said Trump
commented this is really a bigger job
than I thought which is good he should
think that Trump is apparently learning
very quickly pack that being president
of the United States is not just posting
on Twitter and convincing heads of state
to state your hotel when they come to
visit it's sort of the biggest job there
is and uh it's it's very funny that now
of course Newt Gingrich is spinning it
is positive it's great that Trump is
realizing how big the job is shouldn't
he maybe have had an idea of that before
he found himself in the Oval Office with
President Obama there was actually this
funny saturday night live skit a few
weeks ago about Donald Trump just being
completely overwhelmed with all the
responsibilities yes to take on yeah and
by the end of it he looks at Mike Pence
he goes you're gonna take care of this
for me aren't you yeah and that's
exactly what a lot of people think is
going to go on that Mike Pence is
actually going to deal with a lot of the
presidential stuff and I know that you
know the the idea of like a test to be
President seems sort of ridiculous but
would it be bad to say hey you know
you're gonna be on the National ballad
and and uh you're going to be a serious
candidate can you just answer in an
essay question about what does the
president do or maybe shadow the
president for a day like an internship
of sorts or something like that this is
not a surprise remember that in January
Trump was interviewed
CBS News is John Dickerson and Dickerson
asked Trump when you think of the
presidency the day-to-day not the show
part what is that going to be like what
do you think about it Donald Trump
responded I don't think about it and
that has become abundantly clear in the
several weeks not nearly a month now
post the election of Donald Trump so
applause to Newt Gingrich for being up
front about this trying to spin it
positively but it confirms every single
preconceived notion we've had about
Trump having no idea what on earth he's
in for and perhaps this is the most
concerning when it comes to foreign
policy because he's mentioned that he
would just learn all the policy papers
once he takes office and now we're
learning he's not even getting many
briefings not only that the guy whose
biographer or not biographer co-author
of the art of the deal Tony Tony short
said he would be shocked if Trump had
read a single book cover to cover in the
last 40 years he's gonna start learning
from reading white papers in position
papers it's totally laughable discuss
this with me and with our other audience
members on our reddit discussion forum
at david pakman.com slash reddit that is
re d di t